[Music]
what is happening right now I don't know
let's try and leave and see what happens
wow that's an expensive door mm-hmm in
the studio that brought you Shrek Kung
Fu Panda and Madagascar
hi I'm George beard it is my best friend
Harold Hutchins we just make comics and
try to make each other laugh and this
old guy is mr. George
he's the worst principal in the world
ever since you attended this school
you've been responsible for one prank
after another really hard to pull off
like that tiger or that tiger was crazy
ah I told you I would get you one day
I'm going to have you to put the ping
down mr. crup a wheel you will obey
every command this summer come sidekick
[Music]
what's robably you'll get them their
greatest creation Captain Underpants you
can't actually fly I take to the sky
like an Oscar wow he is super dumb it is
now
his problems based on the worldwide
phenomenon hi your class I'm the cool
new teacher not some scary guy with a
secret evil agenda guys I totally got
this
yeah totally he's got it Kevin Hart Ed
Helms Thomas Middleditch knit crawl when
it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks Captain Underpants four so
you're trapped in some sort of invisible
box like prison is it okay that I'm kind
of loving this
yep enough I will said you breathe oh we
don't have any talking candle sticks but
if that's the deal-breaker will cram one
in there somewhere
[Music]